better partnering fun like okay yeah oh
so you got to sign each other okay
that's your teamwork all right yeah
who's more likely to be favored by their
in-laws
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm moving on um who's more likely to
embarrass their significant effort
that makes perfect sense yeah that makes
perfect sense okay um who's more likely
to be late to set
[Music]
yeah who's more likely to forget their
lines
oh yeah
that's oh oh you're saying you ooh okay
well see I just will say other things
okay okay it won't be the line but it'll
got some other stuff last one and this
is the most important one who has the
better dance moves Nina
Adam
I'm gonna switch this I mean we it
rotates depends on the setting